ce premier ministre bonjour d'abord quel
bon vent vous amène à montréal invité
avec l'ensemble la délégation qui
manqueront pas à prendre par la 24è
enfants
nos amériques
je suis fier d'y prendre part et comment
est ce qu'on peut qualifier les échanges
que vous avez jusqu'à présent avec vos
interlocuteurs canadiens ou étrangers
votre futur très intéressant j'ai
compris la nécessité de venir à ces
formes des échanges sont très bénéfiques
pour est ce que vous pensez aussi à voir
un petit peu joué sur les perceptions à
propos de votre pays parce que vous
savez qu'on dit de loin des yeux loin du
coeur
les gens en parlent de votre pays à
distance mais quand vous êtes là vous
êtes un peu le meilleur ambassadeur pour
donner l'heure juste et sous pensez vous
avez un petit peu changé les perceptions
à propos du pays
nous avons toujours estimé que la
répétition la meilleure de sciences l on
a entendu parler mais il était important
de venir une fois de plus parler l'a
martèlé sont en réalité que nous avons
apporté une contribution dans la vraie
perception de réalité les parents de
perception l'un des problèmes qu'il soit
invoquée à l'extérieur c'est le problème
sécuritaire
qu'est ce que peut nous dire à ce sujet
aujourd'hui
pas plus tard qu'il ya quelques jours
encore on appris le décès d'un d'un
activiste la lucha qui mord à goma
alors dont 6 l'an de nouvelles arrivent
ici au compte gouttes mais ça crée une
perception c'est quoi la réalité en
matière de sur le plan sécuritaire en ce
moment en rdc
il est vrai que la rdc a été confronté
attaque pour une sécurité mais pour le
moment je voulais dire que le pays est
sécurisé il ya yab le péril en la
demeure
les les forces négatives qui opéra l'est
du pays ont été démontés les les femmes
décès contre la situation dans cette
situation sous contrôle au niveau du
sang du pays où il y avait une milice
armée qui avait sauvé les terrorismes de
des actes de barbarie
cette milice a été demandée elle était
intéressée au jour d'aujourd'hui on peut
donc affirmer avec force que la
situation est stable il ya plus des
questions des circuits complets auquel
nous sommes à mesure donc d'aller aux
élections dans des conditions très bien
vous anticipez anticiper la prochaine
question d'ordre la question des
élections
le calendrier électoral est très claire
on sait que à la fin de l'année d'avant
les élections à la fois présidentielle
législatives ainsi de suite
est-ce que vous pouvez rassurer ceux qui
nous écoutent en ce moment que le cc
scrutant la auront effectivement lieu
l'organisation des élections constitue
la première mission du gouvernement
national que je dirige le 16 mai de
l'année dernière nous avons pris
l'engagement d'offrir au peuple
congolais les meilleures élections de
son histoire récente
je puis donc dire ici répété que les
élections se tiendront à la date qui est
fixé donc le 23 décembre 2018
ces élections c'était un défi nous avons
pris l'engagement devant les verts on va
le faire donc je confirme que ces
élections auront lieu le 23 décembre est
déjà dans quelques trois semaines c'est
lé début du dépôt des candidatures est
ce que vos compatriotes qui sont au
canada dans la diaspora en france
partout et ce qu'ils pourront prendre
part au vote
nous aurions bien aimé qu'ils le
prennent pas au vote mais des
contraintes techniques et autres n'ont
pas permis que c'est la surface du moins
pour ces élections mais à l'avenir il
prendra bien part aux élections et
l'autre problème à propos des élections
c'est de savoir si le président va tenir
parole c'est à dire que linda père se
représenter pour un troisième mandat
comme le lui interdit la constitution
vous êtes sont proches collaborateurs
dont vous pouvez nous dire son état
d'esprit à ce sujet une intéressante
question
le président de la république a dit ray
dit qu'il va respecter la constitution
nous sommes à quelques semaines comme je
viens de l'indiquer du dvi l'opération
de dépôt des candidatures au niveau
provincial et amar en vue il
à une altération le projet de les
élections donc on s'y limitent à
l'esprit et la lettre cette notion qui
peut voir la limitation de mandats à
deux et donc le présent joseph kabila
c'est un nom je me permets de le dire et
non m'a félicité dans la région lui
respecte la constitution alors que tous
les pays qui entourent la rdc ont
procédé à des révisions pour permettre
au chef de l'état de se présenter à
advitam eternam donc la rdc est le seul
pays au niveau de l'afrique centrale où
la constitution n'essaiera pas remisé
dans l'essence de permettre au chef de
l'état de se présenter autant de fois
qu'il faudra donc c c'est pour vous dire
que le présent dans le public qui s'est
prononcé en vêtements pour le respect de
la constitution laissait rabat ne sera
pas candidat
cette élection présidentielle il s'en
tient à la lettre de la constitution
tout cas voilà qui est assez claire bons
ballons
vous êtes un des ténors l'union pour la
démocratie et le progrès social vous
avez été un des proches collaborateurs
de faits scientifiques est dit est ce
que vous considérez comme en
cohabitation avec le président kabila ou
faisant désormais parti de la majorité
présidentielle
nous avons signé un accord politique
inclusif le 31 décembre 2016
la corde la ccv ce qu on appelle cet
accord implique ou quoi
la gestion consensuelle du pays pendant
la période qui nous sépare des élections
et au niveau de cet accord il n'y a pas
que le rassemblement ma plateforme et
qui en fait partie il ya l'opposition 18
octobre et qui en fait partie et à la
société civile
il ya là l'opposition républicaine
ensemble avec la majorité présidentielle
nous formons et le gouvernement d'union
nationale est donc à ce titre je me
considère comme allié dans dans le sens
de cet accord dans les cra de la gestion
consensuelle du gouvernement mais nous
sommes en train d'aller présentement
vers la tunisie figure des élections et
comme c'est là
s'expliquant par les circonstances il ya
deux ans les alliances qui peuvent se
créer dans naissance de parvenir à
obtenir la majorité donc à diriger
donc on ne peut pas dire que bruno tu
vas là et fait partie de la majorité
présidentielle loin de là le s'en faut
nous sommes alliés dans le gras de la
gestion du pays avant les élections mais
vous êtes membre de l'ue dps je ne suis
faut pas poser la question en termes si
je suis membre
je suis président de l'ue des baisses
c'est à dire le parti qu'a été créé le
requin sur rien et donc je suis au
fondateur historique
si aujourd'hui on parle d'autrui
d'épaisses mais c'est du dp ce bal l eau
nous efforçons haut niveau la justice et
de mettre fin à ces jus des pressoirs
qui nous n'aurons pas ce parti qui a été
avant tout un mouvement de libération de
notre peuple avant d'être partis
classiques et donc je suis le président
depuis du ps aujourd'hui comme je me
saoule et trouver dans le cas
d'incompatibilité comme le prévoit la
constitution
j'ai désigné un un président délégué
j'assume la fonction d'autorité morale
mais je reste en réalité président de
l'udps et pèse beaucoup
c'est ce qu'a été créé le 15 e rang des
signes voilà en tout cas ça permet de
clarifier les choses par rapport à félix
tshisekedi qui est quelqu'un qui a voulu
se réclamer de la présidence de l'utp
les dps
il ya que dans notre pays où vous le
trouvez ce genre d' aventure mais enfin
nous sommes en temps de faire des
efforts pour arriver à à normaliser la
situation de notre pays au moment où moi
son père et bien d'autres députés
nous nous étions au péril de notre vie
dahan plein clandestinité dans une
maison notamment de mettre sur pied le
parti parce que les gens ne le savent
pas les gens ignorent c'est là le
parterre de créer des temps d'abord une
création historique c'est-à-dire la
résolution de créer un battait ensuite
une année plus tard la création
officielle au 15 février
félix et était un jeune homme qui était
à hausser au cycle d'orientation à
l'époque si vous vous rappelez équine
qui ne connaissaient même pas l'eau a
baissé de la lutte le fonctionnement la
dictature mobutienne à part unique à
l'époque donc dire aujourd'hui qu'il est
président les plaisirs du dps quelle
idée baisse je ne suis pas là pour
m'acharner sur fg nom qui j'ai encadré
à la demande de son père hausse avec
jusque au moins sortir de la
clandestinité
vers 4 avril 90 jusque à 1 90 et 1 il
n'avait jamais posé un fait politique
qui montre son adhésion son attachement
au parti c'est une ânesse et ce quelque
temps plus tard le président devait
revenir au pays après avoir séjourné en
belgique craint décret plutôt un arrêté
signé par le ministre monsieur jean-paul
lui interdisant de revenir au pays qu'on
a vu messieurs ils ont beau se s'est
signalé dans des bagarres contre la
police belge
c'est à ce moment là qu'on a su que les
bans le fils du président qui était tout
jeune à l'époque est aujourd'hui membre
du parti dans une cellule à louvain la
neuve
donc il n'est pas président du parti il
sera bientôt dans le rang derrière le
l'héritier politique du président
fondateur est ce que justement le vrai
président du parti pourrait se présenter
aux élections présidentielles le la
résolution de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
c'est une solution personnelle mais
il ya des instances qui sont habilités à
recevoir la candidature et l'accepter
c'est donc le congrès du parti
ainsi le parti est membre d'une
plateforme son niveau de l'assemblée
générale de mega plateforme os et
d'issia le candidat et a ruiné les
chances de l'emporter il faut pas faire
de l'ambition pour l'ambition mais il ya
des conditions
il ya des critères il ya des conditions
pour la livrer à se présenter avec la la
conviction l'espoir de l'emporter
nous n'avons pas l'habitude de
participer participer il faut participer
pour et parle de ça il ya un de vos
compatriotes jean-pierre bemba qui vient
d'être acquitté par la cour
internationale de justice là et comme
chef du gouvernement congolais et comme
en politique quelle est votre réaction à
7,7 à cette situation la première sur ce
me féliciter un compatriote qui a été
arrêtée soit finalement libéré est une
bonne chose
il a aujourd'hui la liberté de revenir
au pays des ressources et tous ses
droits
tous ses droits y compris compris sous
le plan politique
donc j'aime plus que me féliciter qu'il
soit c'est une bonne chose parce que des
gens qui disent que c'est un mauvais
message que la cpi est envoyée compte
tenu des crimes qui sont reprochés à ses
troupes en république centrafricaine à
chacun d'apprécier
la portée du geste posé par la cpi
mais dès lors que le juge ait un nouveau
d'appel a estimé a conscience que et il
mérite d'être libéré il l'a fait pour le
reste chacun devrait juger commune comme
il l'entend excellence monsieur le
premier ministre je vous remercie
beaucoup avoir pris le temps de nous
parler aujourd'hui